Simon Cowell and Harry Hill thank you
very much for joining us on Sky News
brand-new West End show have been a
couple of problems with previews being
cancelled some technical faults but it's
all going down to the public next
Wednesday is it going to be ready
are you excited 99.99999% yes something
big is coming something really big
liability Oh Simon
we're both used to the army really
totally but the great thing is that the
audience reaction has been really strong
even though you know like one night
there was a very long interval of about
a month
your face
the musical did you think the timing was
right Simon because it obviously expect
has been around for a while you know
there's been lots of gags about some of
the people involved in x-factor did you
think it was perhaps a risky time that
it could be a bit tired you know what
are you gonna be positive about your
shows and I'm very very positive about
the show as we'd make I would love to
see this show on a big on a big stage
we've got the Palladium of course the
critics some of them are going to have a
field oh but they have that with our TV
shows to be honest with you so I mean
you've just become a father and
congratulations you're gonna be a
hands-on dad again be quite involved in
changing nappies all that kind of thing
I totally think dad's do changing
nappies to be honest with you I mean I'd
leave that up to the nanny I don't think
anybody wants to do that do they I feed
him you know I talk to him play with him
I mean it's very new still but has it
changed your perspective on your job at
all mean for example when Eric gets to
be 15 years old would you want him to be
in a boy band would you want him to put
in your stones gonna be a pushy parent
no I'm not actually if he's talented at
once and wants to go into the music
business he can do whatever he wants and
obviously I'd love him to come into the
business you know learn to make TV shows
and now West End shows hands and records
I think you'll be great
it's budget time here in Westminster
here in London and a lot of focus on
what the Chancellor's come out with four
years ago you said that you've backed
David Cameron on budget day I just
wanted to know if you'd make the cut on
your judges panel I like David I think
he's a decent guy you know and I like
his wife I think she's a really nice
person I know he cares passionately
about this country but I don't think he
there's not enough money to pay him to
come onto the x-factor family you
probably terrible at judging talent like
that you pay a huge amounts in in taxes
do you have a particular interest given
that I mean millions of pounds in how
it's spent do you take an interest in
that well I mean whenever I get knocked
for what I do and I do get that quite a
bit I always say well you know I do pay
my taxes and you know it it helps and
I'm quite proud of that you know here
and all over the world and of course I
care about where it's spent but you know
I do feel there's a sin
optimism again in this country at the
moment compared to what it was like four
or five years ago I think people feel a
bit more confident it's good to be
optimistic at the moment anyway rather
than knock everything we wish you both
the very best of luck thank you both
thank you good luck the good night thank
you